mathias et benjamin sont les habitués du
festival escales d'ailleurs chaque année
ils aiment découvrir de nouveaux jeux et
s'affronter dans un esprit de rivalité
avec mon amie on est venu ici un peu
dans une optique de compétition et donc
on veut on s'est dit qu'on allait faire
tout les jeux est là actuellement il ya
quoi comme ce corps de matthias non mais
après il ya 10 6 mai comme vous avez vu
il ya plein de jus encore du coup c'est
elle je peux remonter bien sûr je vais
gagner de la rivalité mais surtout un
moment de détente et de découverte la
société festijeux propose des animations
à partir de jeux en bois moment de
nostalgie pour les plus grands et
ludiques pour les plus petits on a les
adultes on allait tout petit on a aussi
des fois des grands pères à des grand
mères qui sont ravis de retrouver
l'ambiance des de leur village quand il
était petit musique arts de la rue jeux
ou encore cuisine du monde étaient au
programme ce samedi 11 juin dans le parc
du château de plaisir l'occasion pour
les plaisirs roi de renouer avec les
festivités après deux éditions
interrompu pour cause de qu'ovide après
tout c'est cette période qu'on a passée
qui était difficile
donc ça fait trois ans qu'il ya plus
d'activité planaire et veut plus
d'activités organisées par les villes
dont grass étaient sympathiques il ya
beaucoup de manège pour plaindre pour
les enfants surtout quand j'ai vu qu'il
y avait plein de vieux j'ai essayé la
grande roue j'ai essayé de sauter
essayez le méga toboggan et je trouve ça
bien qu'ils organisent être comme ça
plébiscité lors de ce festival cette
grande roue tourne à la seule force des
bras des employés vous avez deux
collègues et nous derrière qui font
tourner dans une impulsion de part et
d'autre pour donner un coup pour aider
la roue a tourné
donc c'est 100% écolo ça ne fait pas de
bruit c'est très joli et c'est très
plaisant à voir fanfare ou encore
déambulation original il flottait comme
un air d'été pour cette 17e édition à
plaisir sous un soleil radieux le succès
était au rendez vous avec 15000
visiteurs présents